ich kenne es damals auf dem schulhof die
beteiligung der jude das finanzsystem
und die hochfinanz und allgemein hat er
halt eben immer als als [ __ ] die
leute beschimpft die eben gewonnen haben
maxim kolba unterrichtet in seiner
freizeit krav maga eine israelische
selbst verteidigungstechnik dass er
selbst jude ist daraus macht der
29-jährige keinen hehl weder bei seinem
job als physiotherapeut noch beim
studium und auch nicht hier beim
training normalerweise spielt das auch
keine rolle doch einmal ist er hier von
einem besucher antisemitisch angegangen
worden beinahe wäre die situation
eskaliert
ich habe irgendwann mal kapuzen pulli
ausgezogen was warm und dann sieht man
den wunderschönen david stern der hinten
auch nochmal größer abgebildet ist und
das hat die person extrem getriggert und
dann ging es los dann hat dazu einen
kollegen sagt ich weiß jetzt warum du
hast vorhin google heißt jetzt so der
sorte zeigt auf meinen coach er hat uns
mit schlägen gedroht er hat gesagt er
sein berufs kämpfer dass er uns daher
auf dem parkplatz erwartet
um dieses drumherum von den menschen das
keiner irgendetwas gesagt hat das ist
das schreckliche gewesen maxim kolba und
diana brunner sind mitglieder der
jüdischen gemeinde in dortmund beide
kamen die rund
220.000 andere jüdische zuwanderer in
den 90er jahren mit ihren familien aus
der ehemaligen sowjetunion nach
deutschland sie haben hier deutsch
gelernt und fuß gefasst nichtsdestotrotz
erleben sie hier seit ihrer kindheit
immer wie der antisemitischen
anfeindungen
ich kann das damals auf dem schulhof die
beratungen der jude und diese diese
grenze dieser schmale grat fehlt den
leuten einfach um zu begreifen dass ist
schon antisemitismus oder damals ihren
witz zu machen
keine ahnung über die ns-zeit wie juden
vergast wurden das ist auch schon
antisemitismus das ist auch meistens was
am meisten schockt und fast schon ein
verletzten eigentlich ist diese latente
unterschwelliger antisemitismus team so
im alltag begegnet und der einen
sprachlos dann macht dass es einen
solchen alltäglichen antisemitismus noch
immer in der bürgerlichen mitte der
deutschen gesellschaft gibt das
berichten auch eva gruberová und helmut
zeller die beiden autoren sind zwei
jahre lang durch deutschland gereist und
haben gespräche mit etwa 80 jüdinnen und
juden geführt ihr fazit fast all ihre
gesprächspartner haben irgendwann
irgendwie judenhass erlebt was uns auch
wirklich überrascht hat also sehr
unangenehm überrascht hat ist diese
gefühlskälte die dann also wird von der
seite der nichtjüdischen
mehrheitsgesellschafter jüdinnen und
juden entgegenschlägt um die
gefühlskälte war auch das was
letztendlich auschwitz möglich gemacht
hatte eva gruberová und helmut seller
kommen zu dem schluss dass
antisemitismus keine randerscheinung sei
es gebe in deutschland ein
antisemitisches grundrauschen an schulen
universitäten bei behörden und in der
politik natürlich ist der antisemitismus
auf rechtsextremen seite auch unter
geflüchteten teilweise die aus zum teil
aus ländern kommen in denen
antisemitismus die starts druck drin ist
oder in teilen der arabisch muslimischen
community sind ein großes problem
aber natürlich ist antisemitismus im
grunde kommt er aus der mitte der
gesellschaft und er kam aus der mitte
der gesellschaft
also nach 45 war antisemitismus nicht
weg auch elia but can mitglieder
jüdischen gemeinde in münchen erlebt
diesen antisemitismus er hat beobachtet
dass während der pandemie antisemitische
verschwörungstheorien
erläutern vor allem in den sozialen
netzwerken zugenommen haben das ja
einfach der seit jahrzehnten benutzt
sondern narrativ das finanz judentum und
die hochfinanz und so weiter und so fort
und die rothschilds ich habe ich jetzt
auch in wien erlebt dass der teilweise
demos fahrern von 50.000 menschen die
einfach alle diese sachen gerufen haben
mit diesen gelben judenstern
herumgelaufen sind
oder mit kz uniformen und sonstwas und
das ist schon was was neues nicht neu
ist dass jüdinnen und juden in
deutschland immer wieder verantwortlich
gemacht und angefeindet werden für die
politik israels auch wenn sie wie ilja
backen dort noch nie gelebt und mit der
israelischen politik nichts zu tun haben
jedes mal wenn irgendwelche
auseinandersetzungen in israel sind oder
mit palästinensern mit hamas und
ähnlicher das dann auch ausschreitungen
auf deutschem boden passieren dass dann
auch teilweise
gewalttätige pro palästinenser demos
nicht vor einem israelischen konsulat
oder verändern ich sehe schon botschaft
stattfinden sondern fast sondern morgen
jüdische einrichtungen und ähnlichem und
auch einfach juden und jüdinnen
angegriffen werden diesen
antiisraelischen antisemitismus kennt
auch diana brunner die sich als jüdische
lehrerin bewusst entschieden hat an
einer grundschule zu unterrichten an der
die meisten kinder aus zugewanderten
muslimischen familien kommen sie spricht
mit den kindern offen über ihre
betroffenheit und schafft es so brücken
zu bauen
ich hatte ein mädchen hat mich an einem
abend in der klasse hat gesagt ich
wusste nicht dass das du da auch familie
hast dass die angst haben wenn
bombardiert werde dass das irgendwie auf
beiden seiten der fall ist und ich hatte
auch schon eltern die dann auf mich
zugekommen sind und tatsächlich auch so
fast schon wie ihr beileid ausgesprochen
haben dass mich das auch betrifft und
die das so noch nicht gesehen haben mit
ihnen und juden von angesicht zu
angesicht kennenlernen das würde wunder
wirken gegen antisemitische
ressentiments und vorurteile meint elia
bap hin und empfiehlt projekte wie meet
you bei den juden und jüdinnen
ehrenamtlich universitäten besuchen
behörden sportvereine und schulen meine
vielen schulklassen wo kindern das
teilweise von ihren eltern großeltern
und ähnlichem eingeredet wurde dass sie
das irgendwo aus den medien
aufgeschnappt haben aber der lässt sich
nicht wirklich ganz ganz leicht
teilweise entgegenwirken indem man
einfach als jude oder juden vorsieht
wird und einfach so schaut
schaut her ich habe keine herren unter
meine kippa und ich zahle steuern ich
bin nicht von steuern befreit ich bin
auch nicht irgendwie besonders reich und
nicht alle juden besonders reich und
elia berg indianer brunner und maxim
kolba sie gehören einer neuen jungen
jüdischen generation in deutschland an
trotz antisemitische erfahrungen haben
sie keine angst im gegenteil sie leben
ihr jüdischsein aktiv offen und stolz
aus ich bin man sieht wirklich einen
unterschied zwischen den generationen
wenn unsere eltern uns früher gesagt
haben zeigt nicht dass die mühle spiels
oder er halte es eher für dich und die
distanziert waren vielleicht auch
ängstlich kann nicht aus meiner
erfahrung ein versprechen bin ich da
komplett anders ich bin immer damit
offen umgegangen ich bin sehr
selbstbewusst und hab da nichts zu
verbergen ja im gegenteil ich denke
schon dass auch dank der deutschen
strukturen hier wie auch sehr frei leben
kann das jüdische leben blüht und das
natürlich die menschen in port und mutig
macht und aktiv ist dass man das
jüdische leben hier gestalten möchte und
dass man vor allem motiviert ist und
offen und das sind glaube ich viel mehr
attribute die ich jetzt den juden heute
zuschreibt wieder als ängstlich diana
brunner und maxim kolba sind
zuversichtlich dass die demokratischen
kräfte in diesem land am ende stärker
sind als alle judenfeindlichen
vorurteile